herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen die frau bundeskanzlerin hat an
uns alle appelliert in zeiten der
pandemie weiter umsichtig zu sein
sie hat in ihren ausführungen dargelegt
dass deutschland vergleichsweise gut
durch die pandemie bisher bekommen sein
das verdankt sich ja gerade der großen
mehrheit unseres landes der großen
mehrheit verantwortungsbewusster
menschen die in zeiten der pandemie auch
mit ihrer freiheit umsichtig umzugehen
verstehen deshalb der bundeskanzlerin
war es richtig dass sie heute
angemessene worte gefunden haben in der
politischen diskussion in den
vergangenen wochen hat man gelegentlich
davon gehört es müssten die zügel
angezogen werden oder man müsste mit
brachialen maßnahmen auf die menschen
zugehen so umsichtig wie die bevölkerung
in den vergangenen monaten mit der
pandemie umgegangen ist und insbesondere
angesichts der tatsache dass die
menschen in unserem land
grundrechtsträger sind deren freiheit
garantiert ist ist ihre ausdrucksweise
heute angemessener wir sollten nie
vergessen dass nicht der staat den
menschen freiheit gewährt sondern dass
die menschen nur einschränkungen ihrer
freiheit akzeptieren wenn sie vernünftig
und verhältnismäßig sind ein zweiter
lock down muss verhindert werden sie
haben gesagt deutschland sei
vergleichsweise gut durch diese krise
bisher gekommen
nichtsdestotrotz hat diese krise großen
schaden angerichtet
wie viele familien hat unser staat im
stich gelassen als kitas und schulen
geschlossen haben wie viele ältere
menschen sind in pflegeeinrichtungen
vereinsamt weil ihre angehörigen nicht
mehr zu besuch kommen konnten und wie
viele millionen menschen bis heute
fürchten um ihre wirtschaftliche
existenz
deshalb trägt jeder einzelne
verantwortung aber auch die staatliche
verantwortungsgemeinschaft ist gefordert
jetzt in diesem herbst und winter
maßnahmen zu ergreifen dass sich ein
zweiter stillstand dieses landes nicht
wiederholen muss sie haben gestern dazu
mit den ministerpräsidenten beraten
wie bereiten wir uns vor auf diesen
herbst sicherlich helfen uns nicht
alleine überschlags rechnungen über
dramatisch steigende zahlen
was uns fehlt sind konkrete maßnahmen
und heute auch nach ihrer konferenz mit
den ministerpräsidenten muss der
präsident der bundesärztekammer beklagen
dass wir vor dem herbst immer noch nicht
über eine nationale test strategie
verfügen die die menschen in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen in lehrberufen
schnell und günstig mit einem test
versorgt so heute klaus reinhardt
grundrechtseingriffe brauchen einen
faktischen anlass freiheits
einschränkungen kann man nicht alleine
mit der annahme einer drastischen
steigerung von neuinfektionen begründen
zudem müssen schließlich auch die die
kapazitäten des gesundheitswesens
berücksichtigt werden alleine nur die
zahl der neuinfektionen
ist noch nicht ein indikator allein uns
fehlen deshalb beispielsweise ampel
modelle wie sie von nordrhein-westfalen
vorgeschlagen worden sind das muss nicht
unbedingt mit grün als einer farbe sagen
die nicht zwingend immer für entwarnung
steht sollen nach rheinland-pfälzischen
vorbild kann es auch eine andere
farbgebung seien aber eine solche
transparente beschreibung der situation
vor ort fehlt uns freiheits
einschränkungen müssen geeignet und
verhältnismäßig sein
große zweifel haben wir deshalb an der
im land berlin verhangenen masken
pflicht im büro denn dass er nicht die
orte wo es vor allen dingen zu neuen
infektionen in diesem land kommt und wir
sind erleichtert frau bundeskanzlerin
dass es entgegen der ursprünglichen
absichten ihrer regierung nicht zu einer
beschränkung privater treffen in private
wohnungen gibt hier haben
landesregierungen zu recht widersprochen
denn auch in zeiten einer pandemie gilt
die unverletzlichkeit der eigenen
wohnung
es ist richtig dass weiter ein
regionaler ansatz verfolgt wird und frau
merkel sie haben das ja gerade auch in
ihrer darlegung hervorgehoben wie
leistungsfähig unsere förderer aber auch
noch ist man kann gegenwärtig auch nicht
mehr davon ausgehen dass momentan an
diesem tag unser öffentliches
gesundheitswesen mit der pandemie
überfordert ist
das aber war der grund warum der
seinerzeit eine pandemie eine
pandemische notlage nationaler tragweite
in diesem deutschen bundestag
beschlossen haben die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen dafür bestehen nun nicht
mehr
und deshalb sollte ihre regierung die
sonderbefugnisse in die hände der ersten
gewalt zurückgeben
sonst sollte der deutsche bundestag sie
sich nehmen weil es auch eine frage der
parlamentarischen selbst aufgedruckt ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
bundesfinanzminister hat einen
haushaltsentwurf mit 96 milliarden euro
neue schulden vorgelegt
in diesem und im nächsten jahr zusammen
wird der deutsche staat im
bundeshaushalt sich mit 314 milliarden
euro neu verschulden so viele schulden
hat deutschland noch nie aufgenommen in
so kurzer zeit und hinzu kommen ja noch
die zusätzlichen haftungsverpflichtungen
die unser land in der europäischen union
übernimmt
es war richtig dass während der ersten
phase der bekämpfung der
wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie ein
sicherheitsnetz für beschäftigung und
betriebe gespannt worden ist den haben
wir uns auch nicht verweigert übrigens
fehlen dort immer noch wichtige elemente
wo zum beispiel ist ein spezifisch
gezieltes programm zur unterstützung von
solo selbstständigen freelancer und
kulturschaffende warum warum gibt es
warum gibt es bis heute nicht warum gibt
es bis heute nicht die möglichkeit der
vollen anrechnung der verluste dieses
jahres auf die steuerschuld der jahre
2019 2018 ein viel besseres instrument
als manche sofort hilfe die sie
ausgezahlt werden also es war richtig an
sicherheitsnetz für beschäftigung und
für betriebe zu spannen selbst wenn es
noch immer lücken aufweist das aber sie
herr scholz auch im nächsten jahr 2021
weiter auf rekord-schulden setzen und
wiederum
die schuldenbremse missachten das hat
mit nothilfe nichts mehr zu tun
wir sehen nämlich die erster
erholungssignale und vor allen dingen
haben sie den bundeshaushalt ja bereits
vor corona erhebliche lasten aufgebürdet
alleine die leistungsausweitungen in der
rentenkasse machen 20 milliarden euro
zusätzlich im jahr aus es ist nicht ein
virus das den haushalt ruiniert es ist
eine seit vielen jahren falsche politik
die die staatsfinanzen ruiniert hosen in
den vergangenen fünf jahren mit
vergangenen fünf jahren bis auf eine
ausnahme sind die sozialausgaben stärker
gewachsen als die wirtschaft und einer
ausnahme selbst im vergangenen jahr bei
rekordbeschäftigung und niedrig
arbeitslosigkeit hat dieser staat zum
ersten mal als mehr als eine billion
euro an sozialausgaben geleistet oder ob
es konkret zu machen
hubertus heil gibt am tag mehr geld aus
als ihre regierung frau merkel in einem
ganzen jahr in gigabit netze investiert
das ist eine schieflage ihrer politik
bis verstehen sie mich nicht falsch ich
bin für einen treffsicheren sozialstaat
der die menschen in not nicht bestimmt
lässt an bord
zu einem sozialstaat gehört eben auch zu
einem sozialstaat gehört eben auch dass
er seine möglichkeiten nutzt um dafür zu
sorgen dass möglichst wenige menschen in
die notlage kommen in den anspruch
nehmen zu müssen und genau dort bei
diesen investitionen in sozialen
aufstieg da leistet die regierung nicht
an den reichen das engagement denn
ausgerechnet bei bildung und forschung
wird sich der anteil der staatlichen
ausgaben in den nächsten jahren
reduzieren bei bildung und forschung
mittel nicht zu verstärken in diesen
zeiten dass das gegenteil der
notwendigen sozialen vorsorge die unser
land bräuchte und frau merkel sie haben
das ja sie haben das hier ja geben
geradezu beschrieben wie eine
interessierte beobachterinnen nach 15
jahren im amt der bundeskanzlerin wie
unsere situation im bereich der schulen
ist wir mussten ja auch sozusagen
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp mit harten
politischen bandagen kämpfen um eine
änderung des grundgesetzes zu erreichen
damit der bund überhaupt in der lage ist
systemadministratoren in der bildung zu
finanzieren das war gegen den widerstand
der unions parteien und zumal der csu
jetzt kommt es dazu gott sei dank nur es
kann doch kein zweifel bestehen dass
selbst die maßnahmen die sie jetzt
beschlossen haben nicht ausreichen um
unser bildungssystem aufstand der zeit
zu bringen wo sind denn die digitalen
lernplattformen wo ist die
weiterbildungsinitiative und vor allen
dingen wie sorgen sie dafür dass die
gelder überhaupt im alltag der schulen
ankommt denn digital packt fließt da
überhaupt gar nicht
weil es unser land sich in einer art der
selbstverbuchung ratifizierung in eine
selbstfesselung selbst zentralen
aufgaben versteckt hat vielmehr wäre
hier nötig sparen
frau bundeskanzlerin wir haben eine
situation am arbeitsmarkt der die nicht
allein mit der pandemie erklärbar ist
die ig metall geht von 300.000
potenziell verlorene neben den
arbeitsplätzen in der metall und
elektrobranche aus gut bezahlte sichere
arbeitsplätze
300.000 arbeitsplätze die verloren gehen
das sind 300.000 familien die sich
morgen fragen wovon sie leben sollen
das ist kaufkraftverlust in regionen der
ford-chef bedeutet sich zum handelsblatt
geäußert und frau merkel was er gesagt
hat das hörte sich gar nicht nach corona
bedingten einbrüchen an sondern das
klang ganz anders er hat beklagt dass
gerade in seinem segment der
fahrzeugindustrie es nicht corona ist
das den absatz gefährdet sondern das ist
die klimapolitik und die fixierung auf
batterie elektrische antriebe sind die
dazu geführt haben dass in seinen
unternehmen arbeitsplatzabbau
strukturbruch bevorsteht
markus söder reiz sich da ein personal
fordert auch für das jahr 2035 jetzt das
verbot des verbrennungsmotors sinnvoll
für die beschäftigung in deutschland
wäre es nichts den klimawandel zu
leugnen die manche das hat hier im haus
tun aber mit technologieoffenheit für
verbrenner mit synthetischen kraftstoff
für batterie elektrischem antrieb und
für wasserstoff die weichen zu stellen
damit sich im marktwirtschaftlichen
prozess die zukunft antriebe herausgeben
kann nichts davon passiert und wir sehen
das mit interesse was markus söder da
macht mir kommt das bekannt vor
gerade am vergangenen wochenende gab es
herzliche gratulation an die kolleginnen
dörner von den grünen gab es eine
oberbürgermeisterwahl in form sechs
jahren gab es in bonn einen schwarzen
oberbürgermeister der mit seiner
ratsmehrheit jamaika überwiegend grüne
politik gemacht hat und jetzt nun in der
stichwahl hat sich die grüne kandidatin
natürlich gegen den cdu kandidaten
durchgesetzt weil im zweifel hat man das
original gewählt und das früher von
bürgerlichen mehrheiten geführte bonn
dort gibt es nun frau merkel eine grün
rot rote regierung mit grüner
bürgermeisterin
viele grüße an markus söder wenn das die
strategie der union sein sollte also
frau merkel hier die
arbeitsplatzverluste die wir gegenwärtig
in der volkswirtschaft haben sind nicht
alleine mit corona erklärbar sondern
ganz im gegenteil falsche
grundentscheidungen der vergangenen
jahre werden jetzt mit subventionen und
kurzarbeit überdeckt um noch über den
wahltermin 2021 zu kommen besser wären
besser wäre es fairer rahmenbedingungen
besser während faire rahmenbedingungen
es kann ja überhaupt gar kein zweifel
daran bestehen dass wir zielkonflikte
haben etwa zwischen dem klimaschutz und
der beschäftigung
diese zielkonflikte kann man auch nicht
leugnen sondern müssen eine politik
formulieren die die unterschiedlichen
ziele nämlich beschäftigung einerseits
und andererseits klima zeugen
klimafreundlichkeit verbindet da sind
wir alle gefordert
dafür brauchen wir faire
rahmenbedingungen und vor allem die
einsicht auch in das physikalisch
möglichen
da brauchen wir an eine umkehrung der
wirtschaftsminister altmaier hat einen
entwurf vorgelegt für an die eg 2021 und
bis 2030 er altmaier gehen sie
unverändert von einem strombedarf von
580 terawattstunden im jahr aus wie ist
es dann eigentlich mit der
elektrifizierung der fahrzeugflotte
wie ist es eigentlich dass sie bei der
stahlproduktion ausschließlich auf
grünen wasserstoff setzen der aus dem
strom kommt und gleichzeitig steigen wir
aus kernenergie und kohle aus ihr
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz herr
altmaier macht nicht nur die energie in
deutschland teuer und damit
arbeitsplätze weniger wettbewerbsfähig
sie sorgen dafür dass herr scholz uns
nicht nur eine haushaltslücke
hinterlässt sondern sie der nächsten
regierung auch an eine stromlücke für
die nächsten jahre
das werden wir aufarbeiten müssen durch
ein anderes ein marktwirtschaftliches
system und übrigens apropos
energiesicherheit
wir steigen aus der kernenergie aus wir
steigen aus der kohle aus und ich habe
gelesen
letztlich wollen bündnis 90 die grünen
nun auch quasi sofort aus dem gas
aussteigen so lese ich zumindestens den
gastbeitrag den ihre parteivorsitzender
gestern in der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung verfasst hat sie wendet sich
gegen nord stream zweiter werden
allerdings nicht nur aussteigen können
aus energieträgern
wir werden übergangsweise auch noch
andere energieträger brauchen
tatsächlich beim nordström 2 ist ein
moratorium nötig aber nicht aus
energiepolitischen gründen sondern weil
wir nicht tolerieren können
das in europa giftanschläge mitgift das
vom völkerrecht untersagt ist
unternommen werden wir sollten aber
nicht dauerhaft außer habe ich die
infrastruktur aussteigen sollen die
voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass das
in europa möglich ist durch
verabredungen mit transitstaaten und der
ukraine
wir sollten dafür sorgen dass wir wenn
wir noch über längere zeit gas nutzen
andere technologien wie etwa die
speicherung von co2 nutzbar machen dann
ist das auch vereinbar mit
klimafreundlichkeit auf russland sollten
wir nicht mit dem dauerhaften stopp
eines infrastrukturprojekts reagieren
zumindest so lange nicht wie wir
hoffnung haben dürfen dass der einst
eine demokratische regierung dort auf
wirtschaftliche prosperität angewiesen
ist was wir tun können liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und frau merkel ist dass
wir auch den ankündigungen die sie
gerade hier geäußert haben taten folgen
lassen
in dem der deutsche bundestag magnitski
gesetzgebung einführt damit wir nicht
ganze bevölkerungen mit sanktionen
treffen sondern sie zielgerichtet auf
diejenigen konzentrieren können wie etwa
die unterstützung von putin die auch
verantwortung tragen für
menschenrechtsverletzungen
das wäre ein zuwachs an frau
bundeskanzlerin frau bundeskanzlerin
wenn anton börner der jetzt neuer
präsident des außenhandels wird wenn der
fortan entschiedeneres auftreten
gegenüber russland und china
wenn das der außenhandel fordert dann
sollte das für sie eine verpflichtung
sein ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
sie am heutigen tag wo joshua wong in
hongkong vor gericht steht dass sie
diesen namen auch hier aussprechen denn
wir können eines vor allen dingen für
die demokratische opposition in hongkong
in china in belarus und russland tun
dafür sorgen dass sie nicht in
vergessenheit geraten und dass diese
regierung
und nicht bürger und menschenrechte
einschränken können ohne dass wir darauf
zu sprechen können der chinesische
außenminister bei seinem besuch in
europa gesagt wird dies an spreche er
müsse einen preis zahlen
die bundesrepublik deutschland trotz
aller exportorientierung sollte klar
machen
bei menschenrechten und den rechten der
demokratischen opposition sind wir
bereit diesen preis zu zahlen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herr scholz hinterlässt einen haushalt
mit 42,5 milliarden euro handlungsbedarf
ab 2022
und daran wird sie dort ein neuer
politischer aushandlungsprozess eine
richtungs auseinandersetzung festmachen
herr scholz spricht jetzt schon von
steuereinheit steuererhöhungen
bezeichnenderweise herr scholz übrigens
nicht das war zunächst nicht erstes
argument zur deckung von laufenden
einnahmen sondern sie haben das
gewissermaßen aus gerechtigkeitsgründen
gefordert dass bestimmte
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler einen
größeren beitrag leisten müssen aus
verteilungspolitischen gründen ihnen sei
gesagt die fünf und die 25 prozent der
obersten leister der einkommenssteuer
bringen 75 prozent des aufkommens auf
das ist bereits umverteilung at its best
und wer ist das sind die
familienbetriebe
es sind wie freiberufler es ist das
handwerksunternehmen für das die
einkommenssteuer die betriebliche steuer
ist denen steuererhöhungen einer
wirtschaftskrise anzukündigen das ist
nicht das beste konjunkturprogramm das
wir uns vorstellen können sondern ganz
im gegenteil
was kostet beschäftigen und wenn sie
hier sagen die korona helden brauchen
keinen orden sondern ein gutes gehalt
dann ist ihm zu stiften
nur selbst wenn sich verdi mit der 4,8
prozent forderung durchsetzt herr scholz
bemühen sie doch bitte mal den lohn
steuerrecht hat das bmf
im internet dann stellen sie fest von
der gehaltserhöhung bei den corona
helden die sie gefordert haben bleibt
die hälfte beim fiskus übrig diese
menschen können sich von salbungsvollen
worten im parlament nichts kaufen wer
wirklichen respekt den menschen zeigen
will
die im richtigen berufen mit kleinem
einkommen arbeitet der sorgt für eine
änderung des lohnsteuer tarifs durch
einen riss tarif für die menschen mit
kleinen einkommen und die zweite reihe
in stellung bekommen dann sieht vor im
blick die zweite weichenstellung würden
die frage sein wie halten wir es mit
schulden
wie halten wir es mit schulden dass der
grünen fraktion war ja nicht nur die
forderung nach steuererhöhungen gestern
zu hören sondern da wird ja die
öffentliche verschuldung auch zu einer
neuen staatsphilosophie verklärt da geht
es gar nicht mehr um die schuldenbremse
das ist quasi eine höhere einsicht in
die station setze jetzt auf dauer mehr
schulden zu machen und das reduziert die
resilienz unseres staates für zukünftige
krisen
es ist nicht gesichert dass wir auf den
kapitalmärkten auf dauer uns zu
niedrigzinsen werden verschulden können
und vor allen dingen besteht doch die
gefahr von inflation szenarien liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
denn von deutschland geht doch ein
signal nach europa aus wenn wir nicht
wieder zur haushaltspolitischen
solidität zurückkehren
ist das ein signal für europa insgesamt
frankreich hat bereits angekündigt bis
2025 wollen sie die maastricht kriterien
nicht einhalten
sie wollen dauerhaft den stabilitätspakt
verändern
wer in deutschland
zur rückkehr zu einer politik der
schuldenbremse dann ist die überdehnte
schuldenpolitik von heute bereits der
anfang der europäischen schuldenkrise
von morgen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen also einen klaren kurs zurück
zur schuldenbremse eine trendwende
raus aus der belastung hin zur
entlastung brauchen eine
haushaltspolitische wende wie wir sie
schon einmal hatten 2009 damals ford
folgende während der finanzkrise da ist
nicht einfach nur neue verschuldung
gemacht worden sondern da gab es eine
haar ein hartes ringen über jede
einzelne ausgabe im haushalt ich
erinnere mich noch gut daran wie wir im
kanzleramt zusammensaßen der damaligen
koalitionsrunde
und wie wir damals die politik der
schwarzen null eingeleitet haben da war
nicht alles richtig
ich erinnere mich noch dass ein csu
verteidigungsminister mit federndem gang
in den koalitionsausschuss kam und
erklärte seinen sparbeitrag wird
erbringen dadurch dass die wehrpflicht
abgeschafft wird
und da muss man sagen das war ein fehler
denn die aussetzung der wehrpflicht kann
niemals ein sparprogramm seien aber
grundsätzlich war diese
haushaltspolitische linie richtig heute
dagegen haben wir einen
bundesfinanzminister der ja geradezu
dazu ermuntert mehr auszugeben
bei der grundrente gibt es an beschluss
ohne gegenfinanzierung denn die
finanztransaktionssteuer die es bislang
noch nicht beschlossen
jeder haushalt bietet spielräume
haushaltsreste subventionen asyl ruckler
hier hat gestern herr brinkhaus
gesprochen hat im grunde die im
haushaltsplan von olaf scholz in bausch
und bogen abgelehnt
das haben sie gemacht herr brinkhaus
aber hier geht
nicht mehr um fensterreden sondern hier
geht es auch nicht um den
haushaltsentwurf von herrn scholz
sondern wenn diese haushalt beschlossen
wird dann ist es auch der haushalt der
cdu csu mit allem menschen mit allen
mehrausgaben 1200 euro wird jede
bürgerin jeder bürger in deutschland
jetzt mit zusätzlichen schulden belastet
mit diesem bundeshaushalt alleine durch
die auflösung der asyl rücklage könnte
diese mehrbelastung um die hälfte
reduziert werden dies zu unterlassen
wäre nicht nur ökonomisch unklug es wäre
ein schwerer bruch der
generationengerechtigkeit es wäre der
totenschein für die schuldenbremse
[Applaus]